لقد كنت شخصًا نشيطًا، ثم
بعد ثلاثة أيام كنت طريح الفراش على أجهزة
دعم الحياة. يعترف آدم ميلار بأن ذلك كان بمثابة نداء
للاستيقاظ قبل أربع سنوات عندما كان عمره
19 عامًا في كولورادو يتابع مهنة الهوكي،
وقد أصيب فجأة بما كان
يعتقد أنها أعراض الأنفلونزا.  لقد كان
قلبه في الواقع قد أصيب
بالرجفان الأذيني الذي تحول بسرعة
إلى صدمة قلبية وكاد أن يموت
ولكن مضختين صغيرتين للقلب
صممتهما وصنعتهما شركة
أبيوميد في دانفرز أنقذتا حياة آدم، إنها
تقنية لا تصدق حقًا، إنه جنون أي نوع من هذه الأشياء
البسيطة  فكرة السماح لقلبك
بالراحة والتعافي والسماح لهذه المضخات
بضخ الدم في جميع أنحاء جسمك بينما
يمكنه الاسترخاء والتعافي وبعد ثلاثة
أيام يعود قلبك بالكامل إلى
العمل، طار آدم المتعافي إلى
دانفرز وأجرى تدريبًا داخليًا في أبيومد
حيث كان  التقيت بكيسي موتشي الذي بدأ
قبل ستة أشهر في الموارد البشرية،
وكانت قصته معروفة جدًا في جميع أنحاء
المكتب وعندما جاء على متن الطائرة
كان الجميع مثل آدم ميلار
قادم وكنت مثل هذا الحيوان الذي
تبين أن رجلنا سيكون عليه  الرجل الذي
طرح السؤال
بعد بضع سنوات فقط، الشركة التي صنعت
الجهاز الذي أنقذ قلبه
جمعت أيضًا هذين القلبين معًا، أنا
ممتن للغاية لأنني أتيحت لي الفرصة
للانضمام إلى هذه الشركة، ومن الواضح أنها قادتني
لآدم ومستقبلنا، ونعم، أنا
ممتن للغاية، وكذلك آدم الآن أحد كبار الطلاب في جامعة نورث
إيسترن، فهو يعيش كل يوم
بشغف وهدف وامتنان حتى
لاتصاله الوثيق، أعني أنه أنقذ
حياتي، أوصلني إلى زوجتي المستقبلية
وأعطاني  شغف بمهنة